Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Byrd is time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and I'm just checking again on you.
I'm just checking it on you seeing how your week's going.
I know if you live in in Boston,
you'll weeks go pretty good.
You're living in Houston.
I ain't so good,
isn't it?
Okay.
Fucking unbelievable.
How many times,
how many fucking times to fucking players on opposing teams just going to
fucking rile up the other team was some dumb horseshit.
Yeah.
Didn't you learn anything with Aaron judge and a very,
an Aaron judge moment playing fucking New York,
New York up in Boston
because they what?
They tied the fucking series.
What are you doing?
And then this other jackass on Houston
looking at some game film.
It's where they went back to back to back on fucking what?
Whatever.
Valdi whatever's,
I don't know what anybody's fucking name is.
Why the fuck would you do that?
I'm glad you keep doing it.
Stupid fucking moves.
Okay.
You're the defending world series champions.
You don't need to be gone around trying to fucking troll people.
You carry yourself with the quiet confidence of a champion.
That's what you supposed to do.
You don't fucking rile him up.
Okay.
So they can be in the other locker and,
and tell you some,
but those guys cross the hall
then I'll respect you.
I mean,
what,
what did what he said on fucking,
I'm fucking facetime.
Whatever the fuck these kids are doing.
And I know there's a lot of people down in Houston going like,
you know,
okay,
I don't know about that.
All two way thing.
I think that was a fucking home run.
You know what?
I agree with you.
God knows they didn't have any angle.
We could definitively say it one way or another.
Yeah,
look like he reached back into the stance.
I know Kate Upton thought that that's the way it went down and that's good
enough for me.
Um,
okay.
Kate Upton said Sofa players in the stands,
fans are supposed to move over.
Those are the rules.
Mlb shouldn't let fans sit there.
They didn't reach over the fence.
You know,
who would have thought?
Kate Upton was then into the fucking cameras.
Great.
Um,
anyways,
I thought,
oh,
I thought it was a,
I mean,
yeah,
every angle that I saw,
which was nothing definitive,
I could see why they didn't overturn it.
I was surprised we got that call.
But that's not why the Astros lost the game.
I hate when people do that.
Well he missed the seal goal in the first quarter and though they lost by two.
So I mean if he hits that,
that they,
uh,
they would the fuck get the fucking hits.
It changes the whole game.
Did you watch back to the future?
You can't go.
He can't go back changing things.
It changes the future.
The reason why you fucking lost it was because you let up eight runs.
Why did you let it bake runs?
Cause you run fucking social media fucking amping up the red sox.
They got a little more spring in their step going.
I'm sorry.
Did they not respect the fact that we want 108 fucking games?
The Jackie Bradley Jr has got to go up there and give the old right there.
Fred,
what does,
um,
anyways,
I still,
you know,
I still think this thing is far from over.
All right.
You're probably thinking,
Hey,
bill,
while you're up three games to one,
why would you say that?
Because I remember 2004 when there was a fucking $200 million team up,
three games to none and they didn't win.
So it's still,
we till we put the final nail in the fucking coffin,
you know?
Uh,
that's it.
And by the way,
who was the fucking cunt and how the fuck did you figure out how the fuck did
they figure out the name of the guy?
Some random fucking guy,
not one credit on IMD B.
How do they find out what his fucking name was?
Okay.
And then why would you go ahead and publish it after?
What happened to that poor bastard?
Uh,
what's his name?
Moe.
Mikey Michelson up there in the Chicago cubs.
That guy when fucking him and four the people I reached up for the ball,
it just so happened he hit him,
whatever the hell his name is.
I'm glad I forgot what his fucking name is.
Elke.
That guy has been able to move on with his life.
Okay.
The guy to hide fucking hide under the old Comiskey stadium for the last
fucking,
I dunno,
15 years now that the cubs won it.
We finally stopped taking your childhood out on this guy.
That fucking guy in the front or did what everybody else would do.
You realize the balls,
it takes a fucking stick your hand out there.
You ever see you ever like have a foul ball?
Some that's a fucking baseball.
Would you go play baseball with your friend?
The guy who just building an APP with no,
with no glove.
Would you do that?
If the guy the fuck alone,
that's like some shit that morning.
Fucking radio guys trying to be edgy.
They're the kind of people they fucking
put the person's name or there's poor pastor.
He goes,
okay,
you know I got to get security the Astros.
Who's this game?
I'm going to need security escort me out of here.
It's the Astros.
Don't come back and win this match.
Just fucking,
that's pathetic.
You know what about the other pictures giving up all those runs?
Huh?
Do they have security escort them out of the building?
Well I guess they do
about that catchment.
Bennett 10 to end the game.
Unfucking believable.
So having said that,
uh,
the Houston Astros still scared the shit out of me cause they are the defending
world series champions.
They've got a couple of fucking uh,
you know,
tough games here.
But I figured Berlin,
it's got to be coming back any moment to put on his white hat and come back in
and saved the day,
try to make it three,
two.
Then all of a sudden they're like,
why?
You know,
all we gotta do is one,
one more now it's fucking tied up and it's anybody's series.
That's how quickly you can fucking turn around.
It's no different than getting married.
You know,
you're a single man,
you've got the world by the balls and any second you could just fall in love
with a woman and all that freedom you had all that time,
all those great feelings you felt about yourself,
all those dumb sports shorts,
shorts,
sports shirts that you had that you thought were cool.
All of a sudden they just disappear.
You just like,
you're in seventh grade.
I liked seventh grade,
honey,
just try on this button down and it all fucking goes away.
Don't ever forget that.
You know,
it's like a fucking squirrel,
right?
It goes over,
gets a couple of nuts.
It's fucking lolly gag and across the road and all of a sudden a harmer comes
along,
right?
Just fucking flats thing.
I know what I'm talking about right now.
I just can't,
I'm just stunned that were up three games to one.
Um,
hopefully Joel Olsteen,
we'll fucking open the doors to his church and let some people in there,
you know,
let that guy fucking hide in there.
Okay,
Joel,
open the fucking door on eight security.
Is it raining up?
Jesus doesn't want you to come in if it's raining out.
Um,
all right,
enough of that shit.
We still got one more to go.
Uh,
having said that,
I still love the fucking Astros and I love their fans.
It's like it's,
I haven't seen them this fucking amped up,
you know,
since those great late seventies teams,
but jr Richards and all that.
And I love when I see the old school gay pride parade,
a flag that they used to have.
Um,
it was actually more like the gay pride,
like ginger flag.
Like if you were,
if you like gay people,
but only redheaded once that was like you had a flag for it,
that's what their Jersey looked like.
Um,
all right,
here's one for you.
I've been in New York City,
I'm in,
I'm on Baltimore now.
Baltimore,
Scarface reference anybody.
Um,
I got two shows tonight at the lyric theater and then I fucking got Atlantic
city.
I got two more.
And then I see my daughter for the first time in a week.
This has been fucking brutal,
but I had to do it cause I gotta fucking try.
And uh,
you know,
I got a hype,
these God damned gigs.
So,
um,
anyway,
I'm doing the whole fucking run yesterday,
six 15,
six 15 in the morning until seven at night,
just running my fucking Yap about Madison Square Garden and dude,
every fucking,
every,
almost every fucking interview.
Almost every fucking interview is just like,
what are you think about,
uh,
Louis C K coming back,
you know,
it stood up is predominantly white.
And which would you say that it's a predominantly white male?
Patriarchal.
Well,
what,
what do you feel Jen?
Abortion.
So it's such a,
what am I fucking running for office here?
You know all these fucking comedians that want to talk about that shit just
cause they're talking about all of that Shit and getting all political and
fucking
okay.
Dive in into this,
dividing the country down the fucking middle.
I just sitting there like,
why do I have to,
why do I have to comment on this?
So I'll let,
I'll let you guys on in a little fucking inside tiny thing.
I'm sorry,
I don't have my microphone,
sir.
Sorry about the fucking breathing on them like that.
Um,
I'll let you in on a little fucking secret.
This is how I handle those questions.
They'll go like,
so what do you think about Louis C K coming back?
I just go,
I don't know.
What do you think about it?
It fucking works every time.
Okay.
Either they either they go,
well,
no,
I'm asking you.
I'm like,
well,
I go,
I wasn't thinking about you.
You're obviously thinking about it.
You obviously have an opinion.
I would love to hear your opinion.
That fascinates me.
What do you think about it?
Or You just go,
I dunno.
What do you think about it?
They look,
you know,
I'd take a jet tickets,
fine him,
yarrow,
or I think it's bullshit or whatever,
and then I just sit there and I look over and I fucking look at my butt.
You know,
the guy taking me around the radio and it just smiling
the fuck.
Do I take what I take?
I want to be still be able to make my mortgage this month,
if you don't mind.
Okay.
Fucking unbelievable.
I don't understand how this is a more progressive era where,
and things are getting better.
That if,
if you haven't done anything,
even if you comment in the wrong fucking way,
all of a sudden you're in trouble and they take your fucking show away.
I just,
I just like,
it's,
it's fucking ridiculous and I know that I am in the massive majority when I say
that
Jesus fucking Christ,
the amount of people that I saw on this fucking trip,
that old friends I haven't seen yet.
You know,
women are,
you go to hug him,
you're like,
oh Whoa,
is this,
you know,
I want to,
I want to come up with a fucking me to stick the thing where you go in for the
hug and then if you feel fucking weird,
it just fucking,
it's like a nerf sticker.
Something.
It just shoots out between the two of you.
Okay.
I'm bringing it back.
The fist bump.
But you know,
current comedy climate,
what do you is it is,
it can be [inaudible].
All right,
if I hear that one more fucking time.
Okay.
It's like what fucking shows go to a comedy show.
People are just showing up and they're laughing.
They're adults.
They know you're there.
At a show.
I know these fucking assholes.
What kind of a fucking adult goes to a comedy show and then goes,
you know,
I was triggered by that show.
You were triggered.
Well,
toughen the fuck up.
Stay home.
All right,
go,
go watch a willy Wonka and the in the,
in the fucking chocolate factory.
Go Watch that shit.
Go on.
Go,
go fucking home and go watch the muppet movie.
Okay.
You went outside,
you went and public.
You said fucking down in a comedy club.
It's the job of the comedian to say crazy outrageous shit and make you laugh.
You know,
go get,
go get the fucking ice.
Capades that's an most of those,
you know,
usually when they have the star,
The star and the thing is usually a fucking Olympic gold medal winner.
Way Back in the day.
The fuck was her name?
Donna Karen,
who is that?
Chicco one in [inaudible] 76 I remember she called in sick that day.
We went to go see her Dorothy Hamill.
There's a great old Naima,
Dorothy,
Dottie.
What do you mean you're not fucking skate?
And at the fucking Boston Garden,
we gave a bunch of mascots out there looking for a pretty chicken.
You ain't out there twirling around
the ice.
Capades trigger me because my last relationship,
my boyfriend was ice cold to me.
Is there any way you could melt the ice and give me my money back?
Um,
anyway,
so I'm doing all this fucking doing all of this press.
It wasn't all like that,
but there was a,
there was a lot of fucking talking about the current climate.
Um,
I'll be honest with you,
if you come to my show is I've been going harder than ever and I've been
trashing feminists because it's fun.
MMM.
And I agree with,
you know,
a lot of the shit you want to make shitty equal.
I get it.
Yeah,
it's fine.
Does that mean I have to lose my job because I have a fucking opinion about
something.
Huh?
All right.
There bushy.
Anyways,
so going around right.
And all of these fucking God buildings,
you go into the,
you know,
they want like an,
yeah,
you're fucking driver's license and shit like you going into the Goddamn
Pentagon.
So I just show it to him and now that they like,
they like take the thing from me and they stick it in this little ass fucking
computer thing,
scan it.
Earl always dumb shit.
And you know,
they're taking all your information off of it.
So I have an expired license.
Right?
I have one that's not expired,
but I kept my expired one and that's the one I give it.
I give to him.
All right.
It's fucking from way back in the day when I still had fucking hair and I had a
different address.
Right.
So
I fucking go to this building and I hand it to the guy and he goes,
your ids expired.
I go,
yeah,
but my face is it,
you know,
I didn't come here to drive the building.
You know,
it's a fucking id.
You need an,
there's an I date and I'm telling you these guys,
pretty soon it's going to be,
you need a valid id to go.
It's like you have to know where the fuck I live.
That goes back to this fucking guy
who just like,
who caught that,
you know that home run.
Okay.
And now he's cynical and I'm going to meet this poor pass has got us thinking
about his own personal safety.
Like I don't understand how these corporations and all these people were able to
snag your personal information.
People have stalkers,
they'll get all the women out there who literally have to have like,
like restraining orders from these lunatic guys and he's fucking corporations
that you're going to buy fucking chapstick,
you know,
they,
they double swipe you love whatever the fuck they do with you.
God Damn license.
They take your fucking information and they just put it out there
and you know what's going to happen is somebody's gonna get fucking killed
because of it.
And then these corporations,
they're not going to be responsible.
Okay.
I,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I'm just basically,
I'm just fucking,
I'm shouting into a tornado here.
Nobody gives a fuck enough.
Are you dumb fucks are going to go onto that ancestry.com and then we're,
all of our fucking DNA is going to be mapped.
You know what I mean?
Like in what,
what good is going to come with that?
They'll catch a couple of serial killers.
Okay.
What else are they going to do?
I'm telling you I'm doing that whole bit.
They're going to fucking build your robot replacement.
Yeah.
No one knows what I dunno.
I just don't understand what people have against privacy now.
You know,
it's fucking,
you see the look of concern on this guy's,
this guy's put full fucking poor bastards face.
It's poor guy in Houston.
He's probably thinking,
how the fuck am I going to get to my God damn horse and ride out of fucking town
without these mother fuckers getting a posse together coming after me?
MMM.
Anyways,
I don't know when the next game is,
but uh,
people can we,
can we try to stop yelling at each other?
You know,
can we fucking stop trying to peer into everybody's fucking living room?
These fucking lunatics like the fucking Alexis Shit.
What kind of a fucking moron gets that?
You literally bugging your own house house.
Sorry.
It was yelling at the TV last night.
I'm watching the game.
You literally bug in your own house.
You're sending your DNA into the fucking Internet.
I don't,
or what else are you going to do?
You're going to fucking handcuffs for your wrist to your ankles.
Start walking backwards down the street and see what happens to me.
What are you doing?
Yeah,
it's,
it's just so you can have some fucking thing
and you knew you goddamn house,
so you can be like a,
you know,
captain and Neil,
what was the captain's Alexis Kay?
What was the captain's real name?
Do the fucking shit that I say when I'm in my house to try and make my wife
laugh.
I mean,
I don't want anybody hearing that.
that's,
that's her own private fucking jokes.
Then forget about when to get to a God damn argument.
The shit that I say.
Well it's the,
why the fuck would you somebody recording that?
Who's listening to it?
Okay.
There's gotta be somebody on the other side that Alexis,
Alexa,
whatever the fuck it is,
is literally listening to your life like a reality show.
Yeah.
You know,
maybe it was like an FBI guy or a fucking one of those international fucking
Gumshoe guys and they're listening and maybe set a couple of fucking a,
yeah.
You know,
you were trying to talk about former president Obama and you said it was Sammer
instead,
and that was a trigger thing.
So now they've got to listen in on your life to make sure you're not fucking,
you know,
a terrorist or some shit.
Right.
And then they just,
I dunno,
they just listening.
They don't hear any terrorist shit,
but they just kind of get into your life.
Oh,
he's,
yeah,
they were expecting a child.
This is,
oh,
this is so exciting.
I'm so sick of being in this van and they just fucking listens.
Uh,
you know,
do you like gone like one of those flat screen TVs?
You know,
they get the cameras on it like they got,
they ask them,
do you watch people in their houses watching TV?
And I don't know why they didn't just say no.
They would like,
uh,
you know,
we're not going to comment on that or something.
Let me,
let me fucking look that shit up.
Here we go.
What is it right here?
Um,
smart TVs.
Watch you watching you.
All right,
here we go.
This side,
it'd be great for my fucking paranoia.
Para yourself.
Destroy.
Yeah.
Your smart TV is watching you watching TV.
Consumer report finds.
Now why isn't this
a concern to anybody?
You know
your smart TV is watching you watch TV.
Consumer report finds.
All right.
Millions of smart TVs sitting in families living room are vulnerable to hackers
taking control.
Oh,
this is saying hackers and could be tracking the households personal viewing
habits much more closely than their owners realize according to a new consumer
reports investigation.
Um,
all right,
so this is talking about hackers then that's,
I'm talking about the actual fucking companies.
All right,
so if hackers
like one of the,
this is like fucking,
I mean that's like a,
that's has to be a crime,
right?
I Dunno.
These fucking voyeurs these days is so god Damn Lazy.
Back in the day,
if someone wanted a look at you,
they had to walk up to your window,
right?
And you saw him coming up your yard,
but they're fucking dick out and you had a time to grab like a steak knife or
something or maybe your shotgun,
you came out,
you brandished a weapon and the guide,
you know,
ran away.
I mean not too fast cause you can only run so fast with the fucking erection.
And that's usually how people got caught.
Um,
but now they can just stay,
just stay at home.
Eight o'clock.
They start knowing you fucking habits a,
these,
this couple banks every Friday night around nine o'clock when they put,
you know,
kids all go out.
The kids are older.
Yeah,
sit down.
Wow.
Look at that.
Try and doggy style this week.
Or they edit something else.
Yeah.
New rippled to this little fucking TV show much.
I don't know.
The whole thing fucking freaks me out.
Um,
what,
what is people's fascination with that shit?
Why do you want to listen?
Why do you want to look at people?
What the fuck do you care?
Yeah,
maybe because I'm antisocial.
I don't get it.
Like,
you know what I mean?
My wife's social.
She says hi to the neighbors and that shit.
I'm,
if I'm like,
I'm just like,
Hey,
oh,
I go inside.
I don't care what you're doing.
I don't want to,
wouldn't know what you're doing.
I don't want to watch your fuck.
I don't want to see what she eating and I don't want,
I don't want to see your arguments.
I could barely talk to you in my fucking driveway.
The fuck would I want,
you know?
Okay.
I'm going to,
I'm going to fucking watch that.
I'm going to learn how to hack into somebody's TV.
Or I could put on a Martin Scorsese movie instead.
Yeah,
man.
But Alexis is real,
I Dunno.
It's all fucking this whole podcast.
They'll throw worlds.
He's fucking weirded me out.
Now I'll tell you this.
Current climate,
let me read this.
Felix Gray,
which sounds like a,
a high,
like a Hollywood escort service,
doesn't it?
Okay.
Felix Gray.
Can I help you?
Yeah.
I want to read it and I want to Brunette.
All right,
Felix.
Sorry.
Felix Gray.
Uh,
the average American blast,
their eyes with bright screens for 11 hours every fucking day.
All these things are great.
I actually have a pair of these.
He's amazing.
Now you can protect your eyes and not wearing them cause I'm a moron.
I haven't been home.
Now you can protect your eyes with a pair of Felix gray glasses available with
or without a prescription.
Felix gray glasses filter out 90% of high energy.
I love that percentage.
I always go with that percentage.
90% of high energy,
blue light and eliminate the glare coming off all those screens.
That means no more tired eye you can you,
you a boom,
boom,
boom and your blue revision.
Is it thin disguise right?
Or headaches?
Athol Barna,
sorry.
Usually it seems like a hassle to have to protect your eyes man.
And that's why most of us don't do it.
But Felix gray glasses aren't like those weird computer glasses you've seen
before.
There's no yellow Lens Tint.
Donny shut the fuck up.
That's what I always think of when I think yellow.
I'll let the other finger here in an hour.
Felix gray glasses are handcrafted from premium Italian acetate,
Acetate Acetate,
so they won't make you look nerdy.
In fact,
throwing on some Felix Graze is an easy way to look pretty put together.
Sorry Felix.
Grays glasses are available in nonprescription prescription and read us with
free shipping and free returns.
There's nothing to lose.
Don't go another day.
Looking at screens without the help of some Felix grades.
Go to Felix gray glasses.com/burr to protect your eyes today.
That's Felix Gray Glasses,
g,
r,
a y for all you dummies out there.
r a y,
glasses.com/burr and you'd go,
that might be my favorite Eagle Song.
Um,
and there's a lot of them.
Stay in a,
the corner Winslow Arizona,
such a fan site to see
it's an l two bay fucking bowl going into the fucking stands.
Hold on baby.
You're out.
Take a seat.
I can't believe how many calls Boston teams get now.
It's like they're making up for the entire last century roughing the passer.
Go Fuck yourself and you're super bold drinks.
All right.
Then all of a sudden it just turned around.
Everything just fucking has been going our way.
I don't know what happened.
Yeah.
Fumble by Tom Brady.
Brady.
Wait a minute.
The tuck rule.
You're going to the Superbowl.
Alex Rodriguez slapping that ball out of cave,
which is hand.
We never got those calls.
Yeah,
you're out.
You can't fucking do that.
But he's wearing pin stripes.
That's over
fucking God damn Canadians.
They're losing the game.
Ah,
fucking too many men in the ice gala floor right there.
Fred.
No Stanley Cup for you,
sir.
My whole fucking life.
It's unbelievable.
I'm just going to enjoy the shit out of it.
The same way.
Any other fan?
What if everything was going his way?
That's another thing they always ask me.
Only sports shows,
don't you?
I you excited.
I mean,
with all these titles as it sits,
it's still exciting.
I mean,
I,
I w I would be bored.
Well,
I'm not,
I'm a join the shit out of it,
but thank you for your concern.
Thank you for asking.
I know it's coming from a place of jealousy.
Okay.
I know when things are said,
well,
they're not coming from a place of love.
Okay.
The Way Kate Upton was,
Kate Upton loves baseball.
Who Knew?
Okay.
She and after or she'll model.
She a model turned actor.
The fuck is Kate Upton.
I know that.
I know.
She's some ridiculously beautiful woman.
You know I'm more than that bill.
I'm also a baseball fan.
Sorry.
All right.
Kate Upton.
Jesus Christ.
I couldn't draw more.
Oh,
I can't really draw,
but if I could draw a kid for a better looking person than that.
What's it like to be that good looking?
You must just like stare at yourself in the mirror.
She's got the same birthday as me.
Oh my God.
Maybe I have a chance.
Alexis.
Well,
k.
Dot.
And go out with me.
No.
All right.
Kate.
Elizabeth Upton is an American model and actress Upton was named the sports
illustrated sports illustrated swimsuit issue rookie of the year.
Oh my God.
That's it.
Fucking over.
Can you imagine being then fucking good looking.
Why was that good looking?
If I was like Brad Pitt,
good looking,
I would literally be like Ron Burgundy.
I'd be like,
hey,
why come and see how can I look?
I know he's at my eyebrows up a little bit when I looked to the side.
Oh I,
you know,
I would be,
oh,
it'd be very generous with my good looks.
I would,
I wouldn't be like one of these people rolling their eyes like,
oh my God,
I get it.
Stop staring at me cause you just [inaudible] I wouldn't be like that at all.
Be walking around with half shirts and shit.
Eight pack everybody.
Oh,
you take it an anatomy class.
You can see on the entire,
all the hall,
the whole midsection split together here.
Um,
by the way,
I've been eating like shit out here in the road.
My flat stomach is no more.
I look like a fucking turd docket.
Uh,
all right.
You know what Kate Upton looks like?
I look like the exact opposite.
Um,
oh my God,
I look like a fucking redheaded Danny Devito.
Oh fuck.
I just,
you know,
I got here and it's just like I got one of those New York Deli sandwiches and I
just,
you don't,
you feel like you have to stock up because I know I'm going back out.
Like if I was gonna move ever move back to the east coast,
like the amount of fucking Mexican food that I would be eating in La,
the amount of Taco trucks that I would hit,
the amount of Thai food,
the amount of Burgers,
everything that La does.
Great.
I go up to San Francisco,
I'd get a couple of thousand fucking Burritos,
shoved them down my fat fuck fucking throat,
you know,
and then that would be it.
And I would,
I would just head back east and I would never get another fucking Taco.
It's like I'm not doing it.
Um,
I mean pizza.
I mean,
how do you lay off pizzas and Italian food when you're back here?
Cause I can't do it because I got to go back to,
to no man's land of Shit,
bread,
shit,
doe and all of that stuff.
So whatever.
I'll get back on the diet,
I'm going to do that whole three day water fast.
You know where you just drink water and you don't consult a doctor and then all
of a sudden you go into convulsions.
Okay.
And then you come to in the hospital
and there's some guy fucking the stethoscope standing over you go.
And uh,
that was a pretty reckless thing he did.
What happened?
Well,
you let your electrolytes get down to,
uh,
she challenged me and a year a bile juices and eh,
what happened was the,
uh,
the lining in your cell walls.
A Dj too much water.
It says,
hey buddy,
can you just fucking,
am I still alive right now or am I an hell?
Cause I don't know what the fuck you talking about.
Okay,
I get it.
Can I see a mirror?
But see how much weight I lost?
How long was he in a coma for?
Was it like a liquid diet and you couldn't force me to choose where you,
okay,
I'm a big Hollywood phony.
I don't care if I almost killed myself.
I'm just trying to lose weight.
I'm trying to keep my Michelin tire fucking dude.
You know,
somebody told me I didn't know Michelin Stars were the same people who make the
tires
for those of you,
uh,
uncultured people,
a Michelin Star,
the coveted Michelin Star,
you know,
if you get three of those,
which is such a weird thing cause it's usually usually have to get like four,
five star hotel,
you know,
five star hotel is the,
is the new four.
Right.
But Michelin,
it's like three stars.
It's got three Michelin Stars and that means that the food evidently is out of
this fucking world.
Okay.
And I found out that
I thought there was separate,
you know,
like there's the Macintosh stereo and then there's the Macintosh computer and
they're spelled differently and they have nothing to do with each other.
That's what I thought.
A Michelin Star Wars.
I'm like,
yeah,
I mean,
but it's not literally the fucking Michelin tire people.
It is.
And this person would have to look it up cause I refuse to believe it.
And I was just like,
but why the fuck are we listening to these people?
They make tires.
You know.
I mean that's just a weird thing.
I'd see tires and,
and then you're into like a also breaks or something else on a fucking car.
Steering columns.
Something in the tire area.
Okay.
You don't,
how the fuck do you go from radial tires helping me not hydroplane to a beef
Morgan.
Y'All like where the fuck I'm supposed to go to food of fucked is think they
are.
And furthermore,
what's wrong with all of these fucking,
what do you call them?
The,
the Goddamn Mama chefs getting all fucking nervous about what a tire company
thinks.
That would be like a bunch of comedians get nervous
about,
uh,
making one comedian.
Make them fucking nervous.
All right,
I'm speaking to code here.
Okay.
Anyways,
ladies and gentlemen,
that is the podcast.
Uh,
I got two shows tonight here in Baltimore.
If you're in the area,
come on down.
And um,
then I have to at the Borgata and then I'm flying home immediately that goes
hang out with my lovely wife and my beautiful daughter and I ain't doing shit
until the following weekend.
And even then,
I'm only leaving for one day.
Okay.
And then I have Madison Square Garden.
Yeah.
On Wednesday,
November 7th,
and then I have a three days at the unbelievably
beautiful,
um,
Chicago theater.
And then you know,
something all freckles fucking year on the road is over.
Yeah.
Except for one charity Gig.
I have to do.
Other than that,
I'm done.
All right.
And I am,
I am going to get myself,
I'm going to lose these,
this fucking 10 pounds I think I put on in the last three days.
Oh,
I had a good time.
I had a good time doing it though.
Yeah.
There's a few places that I go back to and it's like,
I just go back to where the fuck I was.
Like whenever I go back to Boston,
it's just over.
I go to all the places that I went to when I,
when I could eat McDonald's at four in the morning,
it's still wake up and not have no damage done,
really.
And when I go to New York,
that's just a psych.
I'm,
I'm not going to get a bacon,
egg and cheese sandwich on a fucking roll.
Yeah.
Every God damn data.
How do I lay off that?
Well,
Bill,
you have willpower.
I know.
Fucking I'm streaky so I am all right.
Anyways,
go red sox.
Go Patriots,
go Bruins,
go Celtics.
This is this great time of year where they're all playing at the same time.
Um,
astro fans.
Be Nice to that guy.
All right.
He did what we all would've done.
I would've done the same fucking thing,
but actually me I've would got out of the way cause I want to go to hit what the
fucking ball.
Um,
but uh,
don't,
don't be a bunch of cats.
All right.
If you take anything from this podcast,
how cool is it?
The Kate Upton likes fucking baseball at that level.
You know,
it's about time.
One of the swimsuit models in sports illustrated actually watched sports.
Yeah.
Well great though.
I'm sure she's fucking thrilled that she has your,
all right,
please enjoy the music,
uh,
on the podcast here.
And um,
that's it.
And then we'll play another half hour of greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon
podcast just before Friday with the Monday,
somewhere in there from earlier this year.
Maybe
five minutes ago
because he'll sweet,
because
it's true.
All right.
Long distance hiking.
The last week I mentioned that I went on a hike and we just kept going and going
like assholes,
not realizing that we had to walk back.
Hiking is not like a treadmill.
You don't just get to step off and be like,
oh,
I'm still,
despite the fact I walked for an hour,
I am still only,
you know,
10 paces from my phone,
the parking lot,
my car.
Um,
we ended up going on like an 11 mile hike and uh,
it was exhausting to say the least.
So this person is writing about long distance hiking.
Another great old man thing to do yoga,
hockey,
ice hockey,
and a hiking
know.
Um,
all right.
Hey Bill,
I've been listening to your podcast long enough to know that you love hiking,
you hate getting fat,
and you get easily annoyed by day to day bullshit.
I really think you'd enjoy backpacking and Jesus
backpacking.
I know it's awesome,
but can you call it something else?
Backpacking.
I just feel like I'm fucking waiting for a bus,
picking my nose by Ray to get the shit kicked out of me.
Hey,
you guys want to go backpacking?
It's a pack you put on your back and you go backpacking or long distance hiking.
Okay,
let's call it that.
Okay.
It's a really,
I don't have long distance hiking freaks me out because I figured at that point
you've walked long enough to run into something that can mall you to death slash
rip your face off or at the very least just sort of bite your throat until it
stops feeling the pulse,
you know,
start getting into that next weight class of animals.
I don't know.
You know,
mountain lines,
black bear,
grizzly bear,
fucking Anaconda,
whatever.
Exotic pet that somebody let loose that has no natural enemy that is now taking
over the forest.
Um,
long distance,
long distance hiking.
It's really,
it's really freeing to walk away from civilization for a week or more with the
solid pair of boots and everything you need strapped to your back.
Dude.
Fuck that.
You're more man or woman that I am.
I can't fucking deal with that.
I get scared.
I get,
I get freaked the fuck out.
I'd have to be out there with somebody who knew what they were doing,
who had a gun.
Uh,
automatic to not even semiautomatic.
I need something that I could spray and the general direction of the sound,
I just heard and you know,
if we kill a couple of backpackers,
there's no one else around burying them as optional.
Okay.
I would say leave them above ground because they'll get picked away a lot
quicker.
Then people will find their clothes.
I guess the bones would be there.
That's creepy.
See what happens when you go out in the wilderness,
you start fucking talking about shit like that.
I live in a suburb.
Okay.
There's plenty of people to shoot and I never think of it.
They're right out there.
Right fucking out there and I never think of shooting them.
All of a sudden you get me backpacking or long distance hiking and I'm trying to
think out of bury bodies.
All right.
Every time I finish a long hike,
I come back looking healthier and leaner and feeling refreshed.
Yeah.
Cause you were out there eating berries,
wiping your ass with fucking pine cones.
That's it.
That's why you have a peculiar look on your face.
No matter how much you eat on the trail,
you're guaranteed to lose weight.
If you spend six hours a day hiking with a 35 pound backpack,
there's no need to limit yourself to salads and juice.
I can't tell you how many times I've had older day hikers look at my backpack
and tell me they wish they had done more backpacking when they were able to.
It's a really unique experience.
Experience out there on your own.
Yeah,
I bet it is.
Well,
what,
can you please write back and tell me,
uh,
what you do about animals,
man,
because I'm telling you right now,
I'm not doing this.
Okay.
You know,
I only way I would do this is that if I was in a fucking platoon and we all had
machine guns just in case I missed,
um,
anyways,
oh,
here he goes.
He's going to calm me down and it isn't nearly as dangerous or as difficult as
people make it out to be.
If you stay on the trail,
you'll usually run across another hiker every few hours.
Oh,
that's comforting.
That's comforting.
Every couple hours I can run into Johnny Appleseed,
but during the other hour and 50 minutes minutes,
I'm on my own.
All right?
Uh,
you're running,
usually run into another hike or every few hours that can help you if you get
hurt at bears,
mountain lions and all those other base kill a lot fewer people than Los
Angeles.
Traffic accidents do.
Well,
I used to do a bit on that.
obviously,
because the fucking,
you know,
th this,
you're running into one person every two hours,
sir.
Let's do the math here.
Okay?
Here's the deal.
There's like 7 million people in Los Angeles,
okay?
You can't fucking go anywhere without running into like a thousand fucking
people out here.
You're somewhere where you walk every two hours and run into one human being.
So obviously I can guarantee you if those lines and mountain lions would down
here,
the death rate would be through the fucking roof.
All right?
This is the guy.
This is what he says too.
He goes,
just keep your food away from your tent and you'll be fine.
Do you understand,
sir,
that you're telling me to do something where if I'm too near my food supply,
I could possibly get eaten to death.
You want me to leave my living room?
You know,
why can't I just sit on my back porch?
Listen,
I would love,
I would love to too.
Go hiking like that.
I,
I really would,
but I can not get past.
Um,
no,
I don't think you should be able to get past it.
That there's,
that type of shit is out there.
All right.
And if you get mauled to death as a standup comedian,
yeah.
You've really,
we're just looking for trouble.
Warn you.
I,
that's,
you know,
somebody just asked me to do a cruise to do stand up on a cruise and I,
I told them I wasn't going to do it and they said,
why not?
And I said,
because I'm terrified of the ocean.
Okay.
That's why I don't,
I respect it.
The ocean is not the ocean is the ocean,
but it's,
it's literally you talking about
it's outer space on earth.
That's what it is,
okay?
You can't breathe in it.
You're not.
You can't be in it.
If you're in it too long,
you're either going to get hypothermia or something's going to come up and take
a bite out of yet to see if your edible
or you're going to drown.
Those are your three fucking options.
And I know what you're thinking,
dude,
cruise is a safe man.
You're out there on this big fucking boat yet and until you're not until you're
not,
and then you proceed to die.
One of these slowest,
most terrifying fucking deaths that there is treading water in the middle of
fucking nowhere and somebody's going to die no matter how fast they can fucking
get you out there at.
Somebody is gonna die and people follow.
I fucking,
we did one cruise in my life and I could not,
I couldn't get past the fact that I was on something that the second it fucking
shits the bed.
And I know you guys think that you go,
I've been on cruises and go fuck yourself.
I talked to the band that was on this cruise ship for fucking years and they
told me stories over a little fucking played a Jello late at night.
Those awful cruise desserts.
So poor excuse for fucking,
I also,
I don't like fucking going out there and all of a sudden it's maritime laws and
this Douche bag who didn't even run for office is now telling me what the he,
he,
it's whatever he says goes with his stupid ass fucking outfit.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
they told me stories.
Okay.
They told me,
they told me enough fucking stories about food poisoning,
about shit back and up about,
uh,
one engine not working and now they're going half speed and then they don't make
it to all the cities.
And then they make up shit about hurricanes and then they have,
fuck it.
Trust me.
People have medical issues and having to be fucking helicoptered off in Sloan is
quickly is human possibly possible.
Not to the best possible hospital to the nearest one.
Okay.
All right.
And you're going on a cruise,
they go all over the fucking world and they go buy a bunch of fucking countries
that you wouldn't want to fucking get have.
I've have a Goddamn hangnail in,
but all of a sudden they're the closest one and that's where the fuck you're
going.
Dole.
Hey Doctor Harry,
hack it off.
Fuck that.
All right.
Fucking combined standup comedy and waterworld.
I'm not doing it.
All right.
So that's the thing of it.
I would absolutely love to go backpacking.
I would love to do that.
I would love to go up fucking mountains.
It's way better than going to the gym.
I understand 100% what you're talking about,
but dude,
that shit where you run into a bear mama bear and it just,
okay.
Turns around and just runs it.
You 35 40 miles an hour,
you basically,
and you're sitting there hearing this,
this beast,
like trees getting out of the fucking way.
It's this thing is just coming,
flying down the fucking hill at you and you're running knowing you're going to
get caught and you hear and your stupid pots and pans click clank and together
and all you're trying to do is just get out in front of your friend.
So he's the one that goes down and so you can live knowing for the rest deal
life what your strategy did.
Killed your friends here in his cries,
whatever the,
what is the sound of having your face ripped off?
I like to lose weight like the next guy.
Jesus guy.
You go out there with the a beer.
We have fucking bear mace.
Fuck all of that bears,
mountain lions,
poisonous snakes.
What about if he just,
and then all the fucking varmints out there.
I love that word because you send me Sam's the only person I ever heard use it
and when I found out it was actually a credible word and not something made up.
I absolutely love that word farm.
It's,
you know,
badgers,
wolverines,
bobcat's people get bobcat's like they're no big deal if it getting scratched by
a fucking house cat.
How bad that that thing can fuck you up with its little ass.
Fucking pause.
All right.
You,
you want a goddamn links jumping on.
You don't want to fucking town cause it's board.
Oh,
you're freaked out.
Oh you came near to near something that had peed on and you have no fucking
idea.
That's another thing,
dude,
you're,
you're in their world.
This guy actually actually respected the fact that I said I'm not doing it,
but I honestly,
he,
I think he thought it was pretty peculiar that I wouldn't do a stand up on a
cruise.
I just jumped subject.
Sorry.
And uh,
and I was waiting for him to ask me why and I would just be like,
well,
you know,
would you do a podcast?
You know,
[inaudible] on a,
on a boat in a lake that's full of fucking alligators.
I mean,
you can lie.
Okay,
we're on the boat,
everything's fucking fine.
But it's really is just an unnecessary risk that you take.
It goes all the way back to that fucking saints fan.
He got off easy.
That same fucking guy put that guy with his jersey,
with his video cam camera walking up to a mama bear screaming who day,
who day and all that type of shit.
He's worried about getting spit in his face.
He would have bare saliva all around his fucking neck.
Yeah.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
I've actually thought about that.
Like what do I do if a bear was running right at me?
I just wished that I would have the wherewithal to run right at it.
Like,
you know,
if a shark was coming at me,
swim right at it and it as quickly as you can,
shove your fucking head in there and get it over with.
That is the only fucking strategy.
What are you going to climb a tree?
Things going to go right up that tree.
Do you ever see that youtube video of those guys sitting in the tree hunting
that bear and all of a sudden the bear just literally runs up the tree next to
him and is like,
like I dunno,
seven feet above them on the tree next to him leaning out,
sniffing at them,
trying to figure out what the fuck they are.
And I love how the bears just instinctually instinctually know.
It's just like,
like with that bear eight feet above you,
that's like when you were in the upper deck of a stadium,
you know,
and you shit faced and you get into it with somebody two rows behind you,
they automatically have the advantage because they're punching down,
right?
You're going to lose that fight.
You're going to fall on your back.
You probably going to break your ankle.
Something's going to get twisted.
As this guy's punching down at,
you're not.
Just imagine it was a bear.
That was the situation these people are,
and you got to check out that video,
this fucking bear.
It was on the ground and they're whispering in their little fatigues looking at
this thing and then this thing,
I don't know how it found him.
You just hurt and that was it.
Over this thing was all of a sudden not on the floor of the forest,
20 feet down.
It was now eight feet above them,
sniffing at them like,
Ooh,
is that a food source?
Jesus,
dude,
you really just hit on like two people today hit on two tremendous fears.
I have been alone in the fucking wilderness and and,
and being out to sea.
Okay?
Fuck both of those.
Although I want to hear the stories.
If you do it,
you know,
not if you went on a cruise.
I don't give a shit going out there eating Jello with the date rape drug,
fucking Weirdo,
you know,
to go see the reunion of Wham city.
Lapa here's what,
Hey,
what's going on?
Spilled burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 18th,
2010 how the fuck are you?
I'm actually doing this shit Sunday night and I posted it nice and early.
Look at death.
That's a gift for you all.
You can't shout.
They're bitching about how to actually,
you should call it the fucking Monday afternoon.
You know,
I guess maybe you have a point,
but you know what about me?
What about my world?
What about the fact that I record them Monday morning?
So it's still the Monday morning podcast.
All right.
It's fucking free.
I think.
I don't,
I have the right to name the goddamn thing.
Um,
speaking of which,
if you'd like to make a donation to the Monday morning podcast and actually get
a little trinket for yourself,
go to the the m M podcast.com and get the uh,
the old gee ring tone for your phone sales or picked up last week after I kind
of broke your guys' balls about saving up for fucking happy meals.
You can't even kick me fucking 99.
God Damn sense I'm closing in.
This is just like PBS.
I'm closing on the number that I need to go buy that fucking thing so I could
start walking around doing these three things.
Maybe go to a mall and just,
you can listen to me shit on people for a fucking 45 minutes.
It's actually,
you know,
something that's something I really want to do because,
uh,
yeah,
I dunno.
I like to think I have love in my heart,
but I,
I don't think so.
But anyways,
it was a a,
it was a big week.
I'm just looking at who I wrote for Douche bag of the week and I spelled her
name wrong.
Um,
anyways,
let's talk about the,
uh,
the week coming up and I've actually been talking about this shit on stage and,
I don't give a fuck because it's such a topical bit.
I don't even know if people are gonna think it's funny in a month.
But can we please talk about fucking Bill O'reilly going on the view?
Um,
I gotta I gotta tell you something right now.
I don't like that guy's politics.
I don't like his face.
He has that,
he has that racist face.
You know his,
when he gets mad,
his fucking,
his face gets pointy.
He just looks evil.
He's just not a pleasant human being whatsoever.
But I got to tell you,
he fucking destroyed on the view.
You know,
and I,
somewhere in there was a victory for men because he took on for fucking women.
They were all yelling
and he got two of them to walk off their own fucking show.
How do you do that?
I as a comedian,
I was embarrassed a to standup comic comics just quit,
which is why I'm nominating Joy Bay Har and Whoopi Goldberg is Douche bags of
the week.
What?
What did you think was going to,
do you think he was going to go?
No Way.
Don't leave.
That's exactly what the fuck he wanted you to do.
I was actually hoping at that point that the other two women were going to leave
and then he could just start hosting the O'Reilly factor on the view.
That would have been he just totally 100% dominated at the very least that
segment,
because I,
I don't,
I don't watch that fucking show,
but just,
he just came on.
First of all,
he sits down and he's got on that shiny fucking,
the Joe Pesci shoot Joe Pes Peshy suit.
It's difficult to say Joe Peshy suit and he's got his fucking leg spread like a
with his ball bag,
hang his shiny ball bag.
He locally,
if you ever see like,
uh,
when Kennedy debated Nixon,
how,
if you listened to it on the radio,
how everybody said Nixon won.
But if you watched it on TV,
Nixon was all tanned up.
He had his legs crossed,
he looked like a winner and Nixon sat there with his fucking legs splayed and
crossed like underneath the,
he looked like a fucking moron.
That's bill O'Reilly looked like any,
he just,
he still dominated.
I love when he turned to joy and was just whatever I,
I'm paraphrasing here,
but he was just like,
be quiet and learned
and she had nothing,
a fucking standup comic.
She had nothing.
The whole segment was fucking hilarious.
And when he goes,
uh,
another gem of a moment was when he goes,
you know,
a lot of people don't realize this,
but 70% of Americans don't want a mosque at ground zero.
And joy goes.
She goes,
well,
I'd like to see that that poll or something like an,
as she's saying that the crowd is applauding what bill O'Reilly just said.
So you really don't need to see the pole at that point.
And and getting beyond that,
what he really should have said was 70% of Americans don't realize that they're
not building a mosque at ground zero still,
that they're actually making a rec room with a ping pong table and an area to
pray.
Kind of like they have an area to pray it every fucking airport,
you know,
three,
four blocks up the street at a God damn coat factory is where it's actually
being built.
But the fact that he said that they're still building a mosque and then he got
an applause break.
Joy is so wrapped up into her own fucking opinion that she doesn't even hear her
own studio audience back up.
The guy that she's trying to shit on and the fact that this fucking guy,
he's still putting out inaccurate information that people are still back in
edit.
It just was fucking awesome on all of those levels.
And a,
I like how Barbara Walters was old school.
Cool.
And she didn't walk off.
She gave those two Douche bags of the week shit for walking off their own show.
And then she got him with a nice little classy Zinger.
He said,
Bill O'reilly's on here this week.
When we come back,
we're going to talk,
um,
or he's on the show today.
We're going to,
when we come back,
he's going to talk about his new book called pinheads and Patriots.
And then she looked at bill and she goes,
at this point,
I,
uh,
I'm not sure which you are,
something like that.
It was a great little zinger,
but she wasn't like judging the guy.
I Dunno.
The whole thing was funny and just how bill O'Reilly is,
is,
is viewed as this intolerant person.
And then he comes on the show of a,
I guess mostly liberals,
and then they show absolutely no tolerance for him and then throw a fucking
temper tantrum and walk off their own goddamn show.
I mean,
you can't tell me everybody over at,
at Fox News wasn't literally jerking off to that moment.
I bill O'Reilly Bomas became a fucking rock star in that moment.
I was,
that was like a standup comic moment that he did to two comedians,
which blew my mind,
you know,
and I know I'm always trashing the brides on the show,
but that really was a chick way of handling,
losing an argument.
Like,
I'm just going to get off up in storm Ma.
He is so used to people paying for your drinks and holding the Goddamn door for
you.
You actually thought that as an adult that you were just going to walk off the
shell and this was going to be this big moment and he was going to be like,
oh,
wait a minute,
let me stop.
Uh,
I loved it.
He was like,
go ahead and leave.
I don't give a fuck.
I'll continue.
I'll take over your fucking show.
Um,
so anyways,
there you go.
Douche bags of the week.
Joe Bay Harbor and Whoopi Goldberg for walking off your own fucking show when a
shiny suit fucking I,
I can't say he's a moron because he,
he does.
No,
I mean,
look,
he,
he's very read up
on that.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I,
I'm too stupid.
This is why I would,
and this is right here.
Why I would never engage as much as I disagree with his opinions.
I don't fucking pay attention to politics at all.
I don't,
I find it frustrating.
I find it to be it just a rig,
fucking gay.
I don't give a fuck,
you know,
and I,
so I would never try to,
as much as I disagree with Bill O'reilly,
I would never go on his show and try to fucking one up the guy and think I'm
going to,
uh,
beat the guy in an argument about politics.
It's like he's paying attention to these politicians the way I,
I give a fuck about football.
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna win that argument.
I mean,
one only bring fucking Roy Jones Jr rover and start debating him in about
boxing.
I know.
It's just,
it was,
uh,
it was fucking hilarious at the whole thing was just,
it was hilarious and a big,
big fucking victory for that fucking,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I was high enough as a stand up comic.
He fucking you just tap out.
That was embarrassing.
Anyway,
so let's get on with the damn podcast for this week.
Um,
I kind of liked that you guys liked that format.
Just getting a Douche bag of the week out of the way right off the fucking bat.
Uh,
I know a lot of people in Denver are probably saying that referee,
you called that fucking pass interference on the jets.
I mean on the Broncos.
Put them right down there on the goal line.
Did the jets give that guy a game ball or what?
That was fucking hilarious because everybody in New York wanted to kill that
ref.
I can't say it was just him,
but I mean he fucked up to pass interference calls where the Broncos were Mcginn
the jets receivers add a what?
A fucking time for a makeup call.
Huh?
Hey,
you go mark.
You're fucking,
he looks like that dude from entourage,
doesn't he?
Look,
I got to extend a fucking olive branch here to the Goddamn jet fans.
I hate to fucking say it,
but you guys got a good team.
I'm convinced now.
All right,
and right now you probably rolling your eyes and I want you to shut your green
fucking fucking faces for a second.
All right?
This is what I,
I wait til mid October before I start do,
oh,
we're going to win your,
you're fucking shoppable.
That dumb shit that people do in August.
Those people who paint their faces and have horns on their hats and all that
dumb shit,
and you don't wear a shirt to the game in November to show people how crazy you
are because you don't know how to talk to fucking women.
Um,
this is what's scaring me about the jets as a New York jet hater is,
uh,
not only are they a solid team,
they got luck on this side and you fucking need that.
All right?
Patriot fan.
The tuck rule pulled that one out of the Goddamn fucking mothballs wherever that
one came from,
you need some luck and a,
the jet's got real lucky when the refs finally decided to call a pass
interference they got,
they got and that,
that's the type of shit that happens when you win a championship.
I'm just letting you know jet fans,
cause I know you don't know what that looks like as a jet fan unless you,
you're in your fucking seventies at this point.
So,
uh,
but I do want to say this to all you country jet fans and I was going back and
forth with like 20 of them this week.
So I'm sorry if I didn't get back to you.
Um,
all the you shitting on the fucking patriots for getting rid of Randy Moss.
I got admit our offense kind of looked the exact same,
you know,
kind of look the exact same and look,
the Deon branch caught a touchdown fucking pass and we beat the ravens.
So we're foreign one.
I Dunno what the fuck that means.
Our defense looked a little bit better,
but I dunno,
this has been the weirdest year in history for NFL football where there's just,
there's nobody dominating,
there's just no front runner team,
you know,
and don't sleep on the fucking a Kansas City patriots out there.
Huh?
Jesus Christ.
They got our old offensive coordinator,
defensive coordinator,
old quarterbacks coach and they pulled that fucking play out.
We have fucking throw the ball to Mike Graybeal for a touchdown.
Um,
yeah,
but there's,
there's nobody out there.
Raw Steelers came back big Ben.
They got him back.
I stayed away from that game.
I didn't bet it.
I was like to fucking steal.
It's 13 points.
They're going to cover that.
But there was something,
I got my stupid theory about division rivalry games.
This is something that's an embarrassing,
I'm actually doing this Sunday night so I don't even know if the colts one,
I picked the colts but I had a,
the colts given three.
But these were the bets I had this week.
And you can follow this all along on the [inaudible] podcast.com me and Paul
Versey have is season long bet.
We basically we were three games a week,
but now we're kind of addicted to it.
So now we're kind of up to four.
We're going to pick for each and at the end of the,
against the spread,
the end of the year,
whoever has the uh,
the best record,
when's the pot?
And uh,
I went forward one last week.
I thought I knew some shit.
And this week I got my ass handed to me.
The only game I want I think is the jets game.
I took the jets given three,
I just didn't believe in Denver's fucking quarterback and a,
but I had,
I had Oakland given six going to San Francisco.
I just,
San Francisco keeps shooting themselves in the foot.
Oakland's been paying kind of competitive as fuck it.
I'll take that and I lost my ass on that one.
And I went against my gut that has been telling me that Tony Romo is missing
half a fucking chromosome.
And He,
despite the fact that he throws for 350 yards and the final minutes of the
fucking game,
he just doesn't get it done.
I went against that because I saw what's his face,
Brett Farve grab his God damn elbow last week during the Monday night game.
So I'm like,
he's an old fuck.
I don't give a shit how many horse tranquilizers they give him a,
they're not going to win.
So I lost that fucking game too.
And I got to admit,
I have won money on the jets two fucking weeks in a row,
two weeks in a row,
two fucking weeks in a row.
So there you go.
So if you want to follow along and watch our Ra,
watch our NFL picks and that type of stuff.
I'm actually trying to talk less about the NFL just because I've really,
that's all that I've been talking about.
I feel for like the last two,
three weeks.
So,
um,
and speaking of which,
I actually ran into Nick Swardson and he asked me next time he could come on
here cause he wants to scream about fucking NFL football.
If you guys think that I am a psycho when it comes to that shit.
This guy,
uh,
he really like I was sitting,
I was telling him that bills,
you know,
Bill's jets game where somebody,
like when I was taking a piss and somebody almost pushed me into the wall
because I was one of my mouth so much.
And I was telling him how I was thinking back afterwards of how I don't want to
end up with my teeth on the floor of a fucking half ass NFL stadium.
And he was like,
no,
you did the right thing.
You did the right thing.
You should have talked more shit.
So I gotta get 'em on there cause I think it will be a on this podcast,
do another one of those special ones just because I think it will be interesting
to,
uh,
hear me tried to be a recovered angry fan and uh,
and him saying,
no,
you got to steer into it.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
let's get with questions this week.
Somebody wrote me here and he said a bill.
Um,
I just got the DVD,
let it go in the mail and it was fucking awesome.
And,
uh,
before we even get going,
I want to thank this guy for by actually buying the DVD.
And I also want to thank all you guys who went out and bought it.
It was actually number one last week,
the number one comedy download as far as standup comedy goes on iTunes.
So I want to thank all you guys and it was fucking huge for me to hear that.
So,
uh,
and then as far as comedy goes,
it was only behind,
uh,
the soundtrack to get them to the Greek.
I don't know where the fuck it is now.
This point might be behind some fucking Nipsey Russell compilation,
but for one day I was number one.
So please keep buying it and everybody's saying the same shit who has bought it.
They're like,
wow,
it's even funnier than what I saw on comedy central.
And they took out some fucking
strong bits,
which I really feel that is accurate because they took out 16 minutes of the
special.
So if you think you saw it,
you still haven't seen it.
It's only fucking 10 bucks,
$10 in change.
Um,
so please check it out just so I can sell enough fucking units of this place.
These people I did business with.
We'll actually get in business with me again and want me to do another fucking
special.
It's how it works.
See if they don't make any fucking money.
Next thing you know,
I will be on American idol.
Sit next to Steven Tyler and I'll be fucking,
I dunno.
Well actually I guess I would be on last comic standing when I
have I said anything funny for 20 minutes.
Let's go.
Let's,
let's plow through this.
I,
anyways,
I just recently started listening to the podcast and whatever,
any fucking ways I like,
I'll conversational this guy writes it,
listen to the podcast and shit in any fucking ways.
I liked how you talk about pirating music slash comedy and how it's sucks ass.
I'm an independent musician and if I don't sell my singles for 90 cents a
fucking song,
my music career dies.
It doesn't matter that my youtube videos of songs have,
uh,
hundreds of thousands of hits or whatever actual sales mean everything.
I hear you,
I hear you.
Cause they will not get back in business with you.
Um,
so anyways,
he goes,
I have a question about alcohol.
Um,
I don't drink that much,
but when I do,
I drink excessively like twice a week.
Usually I blackout.
Nothing bad ever happens.
I just like drinking.
Jesus,
this sounds familiar.
Uh,
he goes on to say,
should I cut back?
I usually clean my,
I usually clean my apartment when I black out.
That doesn't seem bad.
However,
most people think I have a problem for getting that drunk on the weekends.
Uh,
I would appreciate your feedback.
again,
let it go.
Was Great.
Worth the 10 fucking dollars.
Well,
thank you once again for buying it.
Um,
yeah dude.
All right.
I got to tell you,
I've blacked out from drinking who hasn't?
Um,
and I got to me and I've always been fascinated.
Oh,
the lovely knee is coming in.
Um,
I've always been fascinated.
It's freezing.
It's freezing in here.
Come on the podcast for a second.
We'll turn the heat on.
Yeah.
Oh,
Jesus.
You know what,
she's,
she just picked up.
She,
I don't know where you got that.
She bought this fucking,
it looks like a wooly mammoth pelt.
You're really into FERS.
Huh?
Pick up the microphone and talk into it this week rather than than me
interviewing.
Not Real far.
Okay.
I got this down to what is fo means fake in French.
Oh,
okay.
Jesus,
look,
you coming here all oily.
It's fucking gross.
No,
it isn't.
Yes,
that looks like that used to be in the back of a van in the seventies I bet if
you put a fucking ultra violet light over it,
reg Brady's Jesus on that from when he banged Florence Henderson.
All right.
I said it.
It's disgusting.
I don't like it like you've made that point several times,
but to you,
but not to the listeners.
I think they need to know God.
Listen,
I'll be the judge of their
fucking,
it's disgusting.
You pull it up.
Hey,
be quiet and learn something and oh my God.
Are you doing the bill O'Reilly?
I'm trying to see if that works on all females because joy just shut up.
You know what's fucked up?
I actually Douche bags of the week.
I actually said joy bay,
Har and Whoopi Goldberg for walking off their own goddamn show.
Quitting his stand up comedians.
O'Reilly in there too or just the two of them?
No,
I said that I don't agree with his politics,
but he fucking was,
he was the man.
It was their show.
They shouldn't have walked out.
It's true in my house.
You walk off,
you know what I mean?
It'd be like someone,
you had a house party and some guy came in like breaking shit was being a dick
and then to make him leave you leave your own fucking house.
I can't deal with this.
And you're waiting for him to say no.
So let's get back to this thing.
Can you please stop buying shit like that.
All right.
You know what else she got?
How much really going to trash everything you got?
She found this cheetah print.
I didn't find it.
I paid for a yard sale.
You're like fucking peg Bundy.
What do you mean your,
your,
your furniture blankets style that looks no,
it's,
it's leopard.
She found this leopard print sort of table sort of something that you,
it's clearly the print on this basically saying,
you know,
fuck your hoary girlfriend on this.
That's what that says.
And she went out and she got it and I'm like,
and she hates that.
Yeah.
And I said,
if you hadn't guessed no,
and I told you to get the thing fumigated and you never did fumigated bill,
whatever the fuck you doing professionally cleaned.
Listen,
I'm trying to help you out.
If you're going to buy something used when it comes to,
it's going to be up against your body or whatever the f are you going to let me
finish my stupid point?
Okay.
Be quiet in learn and you keep doing it.
No,
listen to me.
If you're going to do shit like that,
like stay away from leopard prints.
Might I like it because that's my taste.
It's not your taste and that's fine.
Okay.
But we bought it off of some frigging Yuppie overlay.
I did.
Okay.
It wasn't like I founded mentioned halogen areas.
What's wrong with you?
Why don't you just give the goddamn merit.
They live across the street.
They don't live across the street.
You live far away or throw them off.
My one stalker,
throw him off.
Paranoid about.
Thank you for stopping by the broad.
I am dismissing you.
Oh my God.
Your kick is,
you're divulging too much information.
You're cold.
You're wrapped up in that woolly mammoth blanket.
I don't like it.
You're really annoying me.
Just get outta here.
All right.
I'm serious.
I'm dead serious.
Go out to the kitchen and fucking cook something up.
Whip something up there.
Tweets.
Yeah.
You don't even believe it.
Dude.
Did you turn the fucking heat on?
Cause I smelled that burning smell.
When are we going to step up our life?
I should really take a picture with our life.
Well,
this is what I want to do.
I'll tell you what,
because I keep going to people's parties and they're living better than we are.
This,
this whole debt free life that we're living,
the level of freedom that we have.
Like,
it's,
hey man,
let's go see a movie.
And we don't have,
we don't have to work that day that we can take trips.
And I,
we both had a white trash upbringing.
I'm not in my house.
Brash macaroni and cheese was a main dish.
And you had it with toast.
We used to eat chipped beef on toast.
You didn't have macaroni and cheese and toast for dinner.
Yeah,
we did.
And it was awesome.
No,
but every once in a while we would have that as a dinner and I loved it.
Oh,
well we'd have chipped beef on toast.
What?
Beef chipped beef on toast.
It was chips of beef from,
nope.
Like just imagine if you could freeze a cow.
You skinned it and then you froze it.
And then you walked up to with a hammer and chisel and you chipped off some beef
that's on.
And it came in this,
uh,
this mushroomy sort of a,
Oh my God,
what the fuck was that?
what am I,
I'm trying to remember the name of that movie,
but it came,
it came in a sauce.
This is what you're saying.
Yeah.
And there was this,
I'm not really having a flashback to my childhood.
We had this other meal that we always involve bread cause it fills you up.
And we had like two pieces of bread.
It was like this mushroom,
he sorta looking shit that had these little red things in there.
No,
it's fucking gross.
That sounds grow.
Isn't that Cube steaks?
You'd be chewing it.
You'd be chewing it like hours later trying to get that tendon down.
No,
I lived,
uh,
we always had food.
We know we hit,
we had our ups and downs.
My chuck was like the economy,
there was booms,
there was bust.
But unlike this country,
at some point we hit a level ground and then yeah,
we leveled off,
uh,
around my high school years.
But uh,
but it was a good time.
But what I'm saying is,
you know,
what are you saying?
I'm just saying that we're living like we're still eating cubes.
Yes,
we're doing that.
But we,
but my point was though,
you even said,
why don't we have up new fucking table that doesn't have just
stupid.
Trying to have style.
You're ridiculous.
You always think it has a leopard leopard print equals come Nia.
It equals come.
Does everyone know that?
You think when it comes 30 seconds to wrap this up or vintage thing in the
balls,
I will kick you.
What do you Yoda
in the balls.
I will kick you.
Sorry.
Hacky and pressure.
I've never even seen that movie.
I've just seen enough hat comedy about it.
Yep.
It's so forgettable.
Those are the most overrated piece of shit.
You're going to fear the wrath of the star.
We take some,
I go back and watch sesame street.
Kermit the frog is still funny.
Timelessly timelessly funny if you get the ones when Jim Hansen did it.
Yes.
Okay.
That time you ever seen that one where that guy comes in and they're trying to
teach you about instruments and he comes into the to the music store and he
goes,
uh,
and he goes,
what can I help you with?
And he goes,
I'd like to buy.
And he sounds like a trumpet.
And he goes,
and he goes,
yeah,
my pop,
pop,
pop.
Right.
So you're thinking in your head,
you're like,
oh that's a fucking trumpet.
And the Duke comes back with like a like a snare drum.
And he goes,
no,
I didn't ask for a,
and then he could make them that they would just have somebody play the teacher
teaching you about.
But the guy wearing in the story was hilarious at one point he goes,
oh you're one of those.
Like he kind of gave him a little dig.
Like there was,
there was something in there for a,
for adults and it's still funny,
but you go back and you watch star wars unless you just like reliving your
childhood,
which I understand cause I watch NFL highlights and look at football cards.
I do get that.
But I wasn't a Scifi kid,
but I,
I go back and I watched those and they suck.
The acting sucks in that,
that the fact that they were doing this movie about,
you know,
space and the effects at the time didn't that shit like blow people away.
I thought that was the thing for it's time.
People were like,
oh my God,
yes,
no,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
But it doesn't,
it doesn't hold up.
Hold up.
Like it looks kind of cheesy and like be movie.
No,
like it sucks.
Just really getting to what?
What were we talking about?
I have to get back to the podcast.
All right.
Oh,
I thought this was a part of the podcast.
If you don't stop talking,
I'm going to walk off my own podcast.
That'll show me
in protest.
There are listeners out here.
Do they know your opinion of,
you know,
vintage or old items like,
like a goodwill or a yard sale.
It's fucking gross that you feel like people are,
people either died in it or came on it.
This is seriously what bill things when it comes to like vent,
like I said,
vintage goodwill yard sale.
Someone either.
The thing is we donate stuff to goodwill all the time.
Have we done any of those things on any of those things that we,
God,
I can't believe you're saying.
No we haven't.
I'm gonna tell you right now there's not a t shirt that I own
needs to stop.
You need to stop asking the questions.
Well,
I never did anything gross and like the clothes that I donate to goodwill or
whatever,
it can be a parade if you're not going to be honest on the podcast.
Look at,
first of all,
you go down there and then all that God damn estate jewelry with those broaches
that somebody dead grandmother's stuff.
So what?
That's fucking creepy.
So what do you,
what do you propose to people do throw it in the trash?
No,
I don't know.
I'm not,
people can do whatever they want.
I'm just,
I just don't want you wearing some fucking Jack Klugman old trench coat.
Oh,
fucking itchy.
And it's just gross.
It's fucking gross.
We have the money to buy new clothes.
Go by him.
I like certain vintage clothes.
A lot of people do.
All right.
You need to not be such a snob about it.
No,
I don't.
I'm not a snob.
I not talking about us.
And that stepping it up at your snobby about stuff.
Any stepping it up as having nice shit in here now.
Grabbing a leopard fucking come table off the goddamn sidewalk if you don't
stop.
It's nice.
I like it.
It brings me happiness.
And just because you don't like it doesn't mean that I'm not allowed to be
happy.
All right.
You know what?
You wore me out.
You're one.
All right,
well thank you for stopping by the podcast.
No,
I have to give,
I have to give because I already,
I talked to Greg,
Greg Fitzsimmons on the special one.
So I've already had guests.
I try to,
I try to do the guests thing every once in a while.
And uh,
you're a little pouty face is not going to influence me either way.
Fine.
Um,
do me a favor.
Go out and,
uh,
go get me some ice cream or something.
Can you,
what's that?
What's that shit that the Italians make?
They're that awesome stuff.
Gelato.
I'm not going to get you gelato.
Why?
Because you kicked me out and you're cold hearted.
What if I asked really nice,
really nice taste in,
oh,
I asked nicely.
So what if I asked nicely?
It's too late.
You're not even asking nicely now you haven't,
you haven't given me a chance.
I'm,
yeah,
it's been real.
Listen.
He looked so beautiful right now and I was wondering,
there you go.
See,
that's how you get rid of your girl.
All you did was ask her to do you a favor and they storm out of the room.
So there's another one for you.
Um,
all right,
let's get to underrated.
Overrated this week.
How far into this fucking Paul?
31 fucking God.
Damn minutes.
Actually speaking a reliving your childhood.
Um,
I actually every once in a while go through like I,
I'm really big on the NFL in the 1970s and I own complete,
uh,
sets of football cards basically from the late seventies to the early eighties,
which was basically when I was of the age when I should have been collecting
football cards all the way to the age where I was almost getting a driver's
license.
And it was getting a little weird and my parents were worried that either I was
a going to live at home for the rest of my life or bring a gun to school.
One of the other,
um,
let me get rid of this.
Close this window here.
Let's get to underrated.
Overrated for the week here.
Um,
overrated,
underrated,
this person.
And this is for all any new listeners out there,
um,
of my podcast,
which I doubt I'm going to have for a while because evidently iTunes is done
with me and I know there's a lot of people,
if you are already subscribed,
this was the confusion last week with Brad is um,
if you're already subscribed to my podcast on iTunes for some fucking reason,
you can still get the podcasts each week,
but if you're a new listener and you search for the podcast,
it's not there anymore.
If anybody knows,
any computer savvy people out there knows a way that I can guide new listeners
to find where my podcast is on
Itunes,
I would really appreciate it.
Um,
I don't know if it's because you clicked on my website.
This is all shit my web guy handles so I have no fucking idea.
Please help me up,
won't you please.
All right.
Overrated.
Underrated for the week.
Lady Gaga.
And this guy says a or this woman and I have no idea.
Why is it she can dress like a slim Jim Mascot and sing about being a cock tease
and everyone thinks she's brilliant.
Did they listened to her lyrics and stop telling me she's beautiful on TV and in
magazines.
I'm sick of being told what to find attractive.
I don't know where they get their standard,
but this bitch is ugly.
Granted she has a nice ass from what I can tell by the rolling stone cover,
but I bet it's not even her real one.
A while I'm added,
Brittany Spears is ugly to where does the media get its taste in women from uh,
come on man.
Back in the day Brittany wasn't hot,
you know,
before she went crazy and shaved her head and robbed that seven 11 or whatever
the fuck she did.
Um,
you know,
stuff that they might,
they might actually fix her up a little bit because I thought that,
um,
remember that video she did was she just wore the all red,
uh,
latex outfit.
She looked like a fucking midget.
I don't know what it was about that.
Was she not wearing high heels?
She looked like,
like how she would look like the morning after after you fucked her and you got
to see what she really looked like.
You know,
you know my theory about the,
the whole,
uh,
you know,
women with high heels shoes and you're thinking,
oh my God,
look at this girl.
She looks like a supermodel.
And then you get him home.
You get them out of the shoes and after you'd done doing what you do,
when they get up to go get some water or go to the bathroom,
he just see this midget and a thong wattle and across the fucking floor.
Um,
she,
that's what she looked like in that video.
Oh,
Jesus sees this is why I don't to fuck these,
you know,
something for all you cunts who give me shit about how the podcast is late every
week.
This is why I don't do it Sunday night cause I'm burned out from watching
fucking sports or I flew on an airplane and it's never funny.
This is the only part of the podcasts that ends up being funny is me talking
about how fucking unfunny it is.
All right,
let's plow ahead.
Did I tell you guys it was raining out here today and how every Douche bag out
here,
the second it starts raining in La,
they start driving like there's six inches of snow on the ground.
Evidently it's because it never rains out here.
That all the oil,
transmission fluid and all that just sits there in marinates on the street.
And I guess when it rains it makes it extra slippery,
more slippery than it would be in an area where it actually rains.
But these fucking,
it's still not that fucking slippery.
Um,
continuing on,
these are just ideas.
These aren't even jokes.
I'm just presenting premises that maybe one day I'll be able to make funny.
Jesus Christ,
um,
underrated a pitbulls,
uh,
it fucking burns me up to see all the bad press pitbulls get because some
horrible luck abused one.
What?
Get,
because some horrible fuck abused one into killing into a killing machine yet
again that not like that.
I have one and he's a fucking marshmallow.
You know how since,
uh,
you,
you should know since you have one too.
They're great dogs.
Um,
I like most dog breeds except for the one,
the tiny ones,
but pitbulls especially make great dogs.
They're the chosen breed of evil fucks,
I admit,
but on their own,
they're nothing dangerous.
It's funny to see people act worry around my dog sometimes,
but it's also kind of sad.
Yeah,
I would go with that.
But also I think that,
um,
you should get some sort of training before you get either a pit bull,
a German shepherd,
a a,
a doberman pincher,
and even like a Labrador retriever,
any of those fucking dogs,
because
I dunno,
they kind of,
I've learned through taking my dog to one of these dog whisperer people,
they really feed off your vibes and he's,
you notice I'm sort of an angry amped up guy.
So,
you know,
I'm not going to get into the fucking details,
but I've had to definitely adjust my behavior.
My dog's fine now,
but it got a little shady there for a second.
Um,
overrated.
The Disney channel as far as I can tell on passing by this channel.
Sometimes it's,
it's uh,
fuck.
See,
now I'm yawning on the podcast.
This is all,
you can't sue.
Give me shit every week to do it.
Fucking Sunday night.
Um,
as far as I can tell on passing by this,
this channel,
um,
it's a preteen porn ring.
They take these 12 to 14 year old girls and dress them slutty and cover them and
makeup and then tell them to act twice their age.
Jesus,
what is with these shows where the kids are fucking 14 and they have problems.
I didn't have till I was in my twenties.
I was a moron when I was 14.
And so as everyone else,
I didn't do shit with my life.
Um,
then and neither did anyone.
It's disgusting.
And it's a farce what they do to these girls.
You making my Dick Confused thinking I'm looking at a grown woman when I'm not.
Thank you.
Lead me into 10 takes a lead me not into temptation.
Disney channel.
And You wonder why there are so many pedophiles.
Um,
I don't think Disney's the reason why,
uh,
there's so many pedophiles,
but I do agree they're subtly making programming for them.
I don't even know if that's fucking true.
I shouldn't even say that shit,
but I will say like Calvin Klein,
if I was to guess is a 100% pro pedophile and uh,
I think that he had a meeting at some point.
It was like,
you know what,
there's an entire segment of the human population that is not getting their
needs taken care of when it comes to advertising and that is the fucking
pedophiles.
So with that,
let's come up with an ad campaign.
Um,
underrated,
legendary comedians.
Bill as a comedian yourself,
I'm sure you have nothing but respect for legends like Carlin prior or Lenny
Bruce,
Lenny Bruce.
But Carlin gets dismissed so often in favor of,
of the hacks they have out there today.
Uh,
for the most part,
the only thing most people know about him is that he,
he's the seven dirty words guy.
Really,
that's how we honor a 50 year career of a comedy legend with him scare a bit.
He did in the 70s.
I know there was a supreme court case over it and whatnot,
but it just bothers me to see how many kids today know all about hack comics.
Like,
I'm not naming names and they've never heard of Carlin prior Bruce Hicks or
their work.
It's nice that there are comedians out there.
Uh,
okay,
now he's complimenting me so I can't read that shit.
All right.
Uh,
yeah,
I mean it is what it is.
It's one of those deals where,
you know,
uh,
I think I knew who Carla was when I was a kid because he was,
he was at the height of his career when I was coming up in the 70s and the 80s.
Um,
but I had no idea who Lenny Bruce was until I got into standup comedy,
um,
at,
that's just,
I think that's just part of being young.
It is annoying.
Actually talked to one of my cousins the other day who's a,
in her early twenties,
and,
uh,
I mentioned the kids in the hall and both her and her boyfriend had no idea who
or what that was.
It just,
I don't know.
It is what it is.
Overrated.
Beautiful women.
Um,
I don't mean because they're prone to deception.
I mean,
because some women are two beautiful in this sort of unfuckable kind of way that
just ruined a woman,
has to be a least a little flood.
So you feel like you can violate herself.
It's hell being with a beautiful woman anyways because you drive yourself crazy
thinking everyone wants what you have.
It's better to be with someone you learn.
You learn to find attractive in your own way,
and no one else can see it.
All right?
Oh Shit.
Okay,
these are,
here's his opinions.
That's a self esteem issue right there on your part.
You know?
But I do understand,
do you know what it is when a girl is just so,
it's not,
don't look,
it's a combination of,
of beautiful and just nice.
Like have you met a girl who just so beautiful and so nice and you're so fucked
up and twisted that you can't have sex with her.
You just can't.
You're like,
I don't want to fuck you.
I want to take you to a movie.
You know?
And then you meet some skank and you're like,
I'm not taking you to a movie.
I want to fucking bend you over the dresser.
I believe that's a whore Madonna complex.
My the only one that feels that way.
I'm trying to think of if somebody on TV that you could relate to that's just
nice.
You know who's borderline is that fucking goofy chick who cooks Rachel Ray.
She's borderline.
So sort of like nice and innocent that you couldn't,
but it's literally that quality that just makes you want to fucking,
you know,
I dunno,
I can't fault in it.
Oh Gee,
let's continue underrated having a fun job.
This one is aimed at you,
Bill.
You like to bitch about how uh,
midgets insert midgets more on stones,
et Cetera.
Don't want to work often enough.
Can I clarify that stoner thing?
I made fun of a specific person.
A friend of mine who smokes way too much weed and every stone are out there.
Fucking sent me these emails.
We mean,
do you got against or I guess cause I imitate you like that,
but what the fuck?
That's the standard voice for you.
You find me a pot movie where someone doesn't talk like that and I'll do a
better impression.
But that's what everybody says.
I'll give you all,
he's coming down and put me in.
I'm not,
I'm coming down on my fucking douchebag friend who all he's done is smoked weed
and it hasn't been a good thing for him.
His quote,
I liked to smoke weed because it turns my life into a movie.
All right,
you have a problem at that point.
Now all you fucks who liked to smoke weed and listening to this shit?
I don't give a fuck.
I drink.
Wouldn't that be hypocritical?
And speaking of which,
I'm on the wagon again,
as of today,
I did not drink today.
Everybody and a,
I'm going to try to see if I can make it all the way to the rose bowl before I
fall off to fucking work.
And again,
yawning once again.
No,
I don't know what it is.
I,
um,
I just been eating the wrong foods and uh,
I dunno.
And every night I've just been doing sets and I've had two Heinekens and next
scene.
Oh,
I have this distended white belly and I'm not liking it.
You know,
I was just at a party and I wasn't drinking,
but I was leaning up against the counter and normally it be digging into my
back.
But I had a nice,
a nice level of padding,
you know,
from fucking,
you don't really screwed me up was when I went to buffalo,
the goddamn buffalo wings was so good there that I have gone on a buffalo wing
kick and I found a couple places out here that have really good buffalo wings.
And um,
actually you want to hear the story,
this is what happened.
Um,
I woke up on Saturday and I'll be in Lca or Saturday as they say in Boston,
in Boston when the real hardcore Boston guys,
you know,
I saw him on Saturday.
You just sort of open your mouth,
say Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
Say,
um,
I woke up and I'm thinking,
all right,
college football,
Auburn,
verse Arkansas.
Lsu was playing McNeese state.
They're given 39 and a half points.
So they're going to fucking cover the spread.
Who else was playing?
Georgia was playing.
Vanderbilt was all fucking site and a,
we're laying in bed.
My beautiful girl wakes up and she said,
uh,
and she claimed the fucking TV.
It's like,
I'm watching TV.
So I immediately got up,
acted like I was going to the bathroom,
and I walked out,
sat in the living room,
and I turned on the fucking TV and I started watching,
uh,
who the fuck was,
I started watching the Auburn Arkansas game,
which was fucking ridiculous.
You know,
Arkansas end up scoring like 40 something points and they still lost by 20.
It was absolutely insane.
And so she's like,
Hey,
I said,
I dad's gonna Watch TV.
Right?
So I tried to bill O'Reilly.
I tried to do that and it just didn't work.
Didn't work.
All right.
She had a rough week.
She wanted to watch your stupid reality shows.
So I said,
fine.
I said,
All right.
And,
uh,
I grabbed my stereo.
One of my stereo speakers was busted.
So I took it down to this fucking local guy.
Sky's out of his God damn mind.
He actually repairs shit.
So I already loved the guy.
So I go down there,
I get that taken care of.
I know I,
what else did I do?
I went out,
I just,
I just fixed some shit.
I went out and I bought some stuff.
I fixed some shit around the apartment and I let her watch the shit.
And at one point I was picking up dry cleaning.
I was doing all these God damn chores and I just saw this fucking,
uh,
this bar and I knew they had wings and I was literally going to go in to get dry
cleaning.
I was parked in the dry cleaner parking lot and I look across the fucking way
and there's a bar with wings and I get out like,
uh,
like the Manchurian candidate.
Like they just turned on my chip and I walked across the street and the bar and
next thing you know,
I'm sitting there,
I got a water,
they've got a Boddingtons and I got a fucking order of a dozen wings and I'm
tearing these fucking things down.
Like I'm in a wing seat and contest
here I am consuming 800 fucking calories or whatever the hell it was.
1200 goddamn calories for no fucking reason cause I don't want to bother my girl
because she's watching.
She's watching a fucking shows.
So I do all his shit.
I only end up stumbling out of there.
And then I finally go over to get the God damn dry cleaning
and I come back,
right.
And during that time a buddy my texts me said,
hey,
I'm in la.
Are you watching the Ohio state game?
I said,
well it's going to be on TV.
Why don't you come by?
I figured,
cause my girl would watch three hours of fun.
I have to whisper this Parker,
she's going to get mad.
I figured because she watched three hours of fucking TV that I could actually
have a friend over,
but like it douche rather than saying,
hey,
you know you watch TV for three hours.
So I'm going to have a buddy of mine over here now and we're going to watch the
hi,
hi.
Oh State Wisconsin game.
I actually gave her the benefit of the,
of the doubt that she was going to be courteous and I said,
hey,
a friend of mine is coming over to watch your house state game.
You know,
we can either watch it here or would you rather us watch it out at a bar?
cause I,
I thought she was going to be like,
well know I hogged the TV for three hours,
you know,
why don't you watch it here and I'll leave you guys alone.
She didn't.
She goes,
yeah,
go watch it as sports bar to now I was pissed.
You know like when you have like one slice of pizza left and you offer it to
somebody going,
hey,
do you want this slice of pizza even though you want it cause you're thinking
they're gonna go,
no,
no.
That's okay.
Because that's what you would say.
And you go,
hey,
would you like to slice of pizza?
And they go,
actually I would.
And then they start eating.
Then you sit in there for your fucking mad at them when you should be mad at
yourself like an asshole.
I got mad at her right and we had time to do a quick workout.
I just ate some fucking wings.
She wanted to go on a hike.
So we start to go on this hike and I just started going on to the,
on this rant about the stupid whore TV shows that she fucking watch watches.
And we got about a third into the hike and she was like a wide receiver just
breaking off her fucking pattern.
She just made a right down.
We were supposed to be walking straight.
She,
she broke off me to write and started walking down a side street and I didn't
even give a fuck.
And I continued my own way and we both were hiking um,
separately,
you know,
broke off the whole fucking thing.
We ended up getting this huge goddamn argument before my friend came over and
then there was that whole thing like got fuck,
now I've got to patch it up before he comes over.
So he doesn't feel the tension that we've been fucking arguing.
And not only we arguing,
we're arguing about fucking him coming over.
So I smoothed it over.
She came back,
I said,
look,
I fucking overreacted,
Yadda Yadda,
yet I ain't even,
that ain't even have a fucking ending.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm just going to keep saying this because it's Sunday.
I'm going to read one more fucking email and I'm just going to tap out of this
awful fucking podcast.
What was the point of that?
Can anybody even remember what,
where the fuck was I even go,
I've started talking about about eating wings and being out of shape and then
the end of it,
I told a fucking half ass story about getting into an argument.
Now I can't even sign into my fucking this,
this,
this podcast is literally just unraveling,
unraveling.
I don't even drink today.
The fuck is my podcast.
Here's a youtube video of the week.
If you guys are like,
if you play drums and you want to see a guy who actually can kind of make his
drums and the way he plays sound like John Bonham's guys does a great job.
Look up a John Bonham swing feel,
feel F,
e e l and uh,
and tell me the guy playing drums.
Does not look like a,
was it ogre was the name of the fucking psycho in revenge of the nerds.
Tell me that's not him.
Um,
but hang on a second.
I gotta I gotta get,
I gotta get back here because I wanted to read something about douchebags sports
fans and then I'm going to end the podcast for this week.
This one really,
but I got him at the last couple of weeks were pretty good.
But this one,
this one was not good in the annals of Bill Burr podcast.
You know this one would,
will not make it to repeat if the,
if this ever goes into syndication,
somebody sent me a great fucking email.
Oh I know why because I had it on this page
about sports fans.
Right.
I'll tell you what,
as I'm searching for this fucking thing that I can't find anymore,
God damn can't.
Um,
here we go.
He has some youtube videos out.
Cold reason to kill.
All of these are on the Mlm podcast cause some of these are actually from
break.com and a.
So rather than have to jump around websites,
if you want to watch all these,
um,
out cold reason to kill,
uh,
this is like inexplicably this fucking video.
This is a singer.
He's on the ground and there's a fan doing something to him that I just can't
believe.
And they proceed to have the worst fist fight in the history of,
of fist fights.
Uh,
look up Kendall on sharecropping field trip
one slap Kao at gas station.
That's actually from break.com.
And then look up massive knock out those things that kind of violent.
What the fuck did I do with the God damn email?
This kid sent me,
this guy sent me a great email about as much as people hate the patriots,
they hate the cowboys more.
So we actually kind of,
I give up.
You know what I just fucking give up on this Goddamn podcast.
All right,
here's where I'm going to be this week.
you fucking pricks.
I'm going to be at,
uh,
the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts,
uh,
on Wednesday of this week.
This is a fundraiser for my brothers,
uh,
campaign.
He's running for a state Senate in Massachusetts,
not to be in the United States Senate representing Massachusetts,
but I guess they have a different kind of center to just in Massachusetts.
I'm too fucking dumb.
So whatever I'm going to do at a comedy show,
at the Wilbur theater,
it's my brand new hour of material.
All proceeds will go to my brother's campaign to try to help him get elected.
I'm so come on down,
even if you're not in his district,
which I don't even know what the fuck it is.
Uh,
come on down.
And a,
I'm going to be telling a lot of family stories and uh,
trying to walk that line
so I don't offend too many people because it is kind of a political thing.
Uh,
and later on this week I will be at the Pantages theater in uh,
Minneapolis,
Minnesota on October 22nd and the,
a wonderful,
talented teen idols sensation from the opiod.
Anthony showed Joe Derosa.
We'll be opening for me.
And then the following day we're going to be at the Vic Theater in Chicago,
Illinois.
October 23rd,
um,
that show from what I've heard is actually sold out.
Um,
and I think the one in Minneapolis is coming damn close.
So I want to thank you guys for the ridiculous amount of support that you've
given me and I'm going to give you a fucking hell of a show when you come down
there.
And,
uh,
I think that's it.
I think that's it for the podcast this week.
It is,
was one of the lamest ones I think I've ever done.
Let me,
let me see if I can just somehow pull out of it.
Do I got anything?
This thing this guy sent me.
Robots are stealing jobs.
Robots are stealing American jobs according to MIT economist.
Uh,
forget the recession.
Immigration in the mortgage industry collapse.
Well,
okay.
Why?
How can you forget all of those?
Okay.
This is already a ridiculous article,
but I think there was a point to be made here when it comes to the loss of
American jobs.
Robots are to blame.
And you know what's hilarious?
They got a picture of a robot with fucking arms folding a goddamn sweater.
Um,
that's the conclusion of a con economists.
Do you understand in the future that when you have a robot,
not only can it fold the sweaters at the gap,
it can also be security.
You know,
didn't you guys see Robo Cop?
Can't you see what the fuck is going to happen?
All you morons who are using these automated checkout machines just helping
these fucking guys.
Do you think these corporations are beyond leading you to a shallow mass grave
when they don't need you anymore?
When they figure out how to make a robot that can actually work for free and,
and you can actually fuck it and it feels like a human being.
When those two things come together,
uh,
like when they drove that golden spike in,
when they made the railroads connect,
I'm telling you that's the end of it for you and for me.
Huh?
Be honest with yourself.
Are you inventing anything?
What do you do for a living?
You think you're not replaceable.
They get it.
You don't think they could have a robot.
They just fucking upload every goddamn routine of all time and you just,
you can just have like a a computer screen topics,
political,
absurd hacky,
what you know,
women,
men and women,
dogs and cats,
all that type of shit or just have it to a Richard Pryor bit and have it move
around like Richard and they have a red fucking shirt on like that.
Great.
Specially did.
We're all fucking replaceable.
All right,
why are you going to help him out anyways?
They say that's the conclusion of economists who've studied labor statistics and
increasing job peril polarization or growing disparity in the pay among low and
high skill,
low and skill jobs.
A handful of studies from the spring and summer have picked up steam in recent
weeks and they raised some interesting questions about the economy in the days
leading up to election day.
By the way,
how great have I become reading out loud?
This is fucking amazing.
Now that I've said it,
let's see if I'm in my head and I fuck up.
Manufacturing is still strong in this country.
It's just that robots,
not humans are the ones manning the factories.
If automation is the future of manufacturing and medicine and other fields,
less educated Americans could be left in the dust.
I gotta be honest with you.
I don't know what the way they just worded that.
I don't know where I stand on that.
Um,
I'm definitely think the world is overpopulated.
See this,
this,
this entrance,
like that fucking Hitler Shit.
You're going to have to start deciding who gets to live and who doesn't.
Uh,
Jesus.
Oh Geez.
So I dunno.
I actually took my fucking speakers,
right?
I found this guy down the goddamn streets somehow.
I'm going to stretch this into an hour.
I've got another two minutes.
I found this guy down the street
who I had,
you know the,
you know the thing you stick your iPod on and it's got the speakers and that
type of shit.
When I think broke one day and it just doesn't work.
So Nia is just like,
well,
let's just throw it out.
And I go,
no,
I want to get it.
I want to get fixed.
And she's like,
oh,
she literally gets like upset.
And I'm like this probably just a fucking wire or something.
I just don't understand electronics.
He could just open it up.
You could fix it.
And I find this fucking guy,
the first thing I did was had these old speakers,
uh,
that I hook up to my laptop.
And so I go,
all right,
I don't give a fuck about these.
I'm going to take him down to this guy.
Am I'm going to figure out if this guy is any good or anything and the guy fixes
them,
they're fucking phenomenal.
So what I'm doing is I'm gradually bringing this guy more expensive shit.
All right.
Now that's what I suggest.
When you find a guy who says he's going to repair your shit,
start with something you don't give a fuck about,
like a clock radio.
All right?
Let them repair it.
And if it works,
you're all fucking good,
right?
Because I'm all about this shit by the way.
He's when something breaks,
you go out and he'd get it fixed because evidently there is a pile of shit in
the middle of the Pacific Ocean,
one and a half times the size of Texas and two miles deep of all the shit that
we just fucking throw out.
All right?
And then the sun breaks down the plastic as much as it can,
right?
And then it becomes these little cubes in birds eat it and fucking fish eat it.
And then you go down and he ordered some Sushi and you think you're eating
healthy,
you're actually eating your old fucking roller blades.
So I'm all about fixing the shit.
So this fucking maniac,
he's like really like eccentric.
His places an absolute fucking mess.
And he was talking about,
I want to give away his idea here,
but I'm kind of going to talk,
cause he was talking about how all recorded music since the beginning of history
is a fucking lie.
I'm like,
what?
What are you talking?
These are the kinds of conversations you have when you go into a fucking mom and
pop kind of place.
You know,
it isn't like Kilz snacks.
Can I help complains?
I'm sorry Thera we can't kids there anything else I can help you with this guy
and like to,
he's telling me this shit and he basically broke it down saying that he works
Monday through Saturday fixing electronics shit and on Sunday he goes on the
Internet
and he looks up the heights of,
of like Jimi Hendrix,
all the beetles and he tries to learn how tall they are so we can figure out
where to position his speakers.
And I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
He goes,
look at Eco Simon and Garfunkel.
He's like,
Garfunkel was five 11 Paul Simon's like five seven and a half,
whatever for he was like new,
their exact heights.
He goes,
but when they do the mix they mix them like the,
the exact same height.
So He's trying to tell me that you got to put one speaker at five foot 10 or 11
and the other at five foot,
seven and a half to really sat.
Hear what it sounds like if they were actually in the room singing to you.
And when you really think about acoustics,
it actually fucking makes sense.
I know a lot of you are going like what the fuck,
but I'm telling you this guy broke it down where it made sense because think
about it like if I was standing,
if I was sitting down,
if your ears were good enough,
if you heard a recording of me sitting down or if you stay sitting in a room
with your eyes closed,
you could tell if I was sitting down or standing up in the room because you
could because of the way the sound was hitting you.
But when I guess when they record the shit,
they level everything out.
Like the drums don't sound like they were behind the piano player or off to the
left.
I guess everything sounds,
you know I'm too stupid to explain this shit.
All I know was the guy in front of me.
He fixed this guy.
He doesn't just fix your speaker.
He asked you if he wants you to hook it up and do it the right way.
Same thing with like amps and guitars and I don't have the balls to bring in my
amplifier.
I'm trying to see if this guy's too buddy.
He basically played steely Dan out of one of this guys speakers in it sounded
like two speakers that the sound was fucking unbelievable.
So,
uh,
once again,
I don't know what the point of my fucking story was there other than fuck robots
fucked.
Let me wrap this whole thing up.
Fuck by.
An old furniture that has leopard print on it cause it's got TJ's on it.
Guaran fucking teed.
And if something breaks down,
why don't you try and get it fixed?
Speaking of which,
the blinds in my apartment,
my dog attacked him.
Like 90% of them are okay,
but I need some new slats.
Can anybody tell me where the fuck to buy those?
Because I want to repair them.
Once again,
Nia wants me to throw out the fucking things and just go buy some brand new ones
and it's like,
well what about the,
where the fuck did
to do my other blinds go?
Where did,
where,
where the fuck did those go?
There'll be a great documentary.
He just throws something out.
You put a microchip on it and you just follow it.
You know,
if he could somehow find the thing that ended up in the ocean,
that a fucking,
uh,
tuna inhaled and then go to the restaurant
and just blow sad if we wouldn't fucking work with it.
You know what this podcast is like?
There's a bad thing that comedians do when they're not getting laughs and they
just think the next joke's going to get him a fucking laugh.
And they,
and they just stay on stage and they stand.
I should have tapped out at 50 minutes and just,
and just been like,
I've proven my point that when I do podcast on Sunday night is nice as it is,
that when you come in on a fucking Monday,
that there's already a podcast waiting for you at work.
Little fucking nice little ribbon tied around it.
It's just not as good is when I do them after I have a good night's sleep,
you know?
So,
uh,
there you go.
Overrated bill doing podcasts.
The Monday morning podcast on a fucking Sunday night.
I'm not doing this shit anymore.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.
If you want me to do it,
I don't give a shit.
All right.
That's it.
I gave you an hour and five minutes.
Not of a hundred percent mediocrity.
I started off.
All right.
But I think in general,
this one sucked a big bag of elk dick,
as they say in comedy business.
All right.
That's it.
That's the part.
That's the podcast for this week.
And,
uh,
I'll talk to you next week on Monday morning,
and you can fucking wait for the cunt face.
[inaudible].